it was mimetic after all this all began
with dr. bang being booted out of the
foundation I started working with dr.
bang five years after I got my
bachelor's and getting recruited more
visit my [ __ ] laude and all that he was a
charming guy humorous but never losing
his cool and works really hard it stayed
this way until 1020 years ago he claimed
he was under the effect of a stone in
his desk a stone that caused people to
lose interest in work to lose willpower
for innovation a procrastination Rock
Maggie and I thought it was a joke it
wasn't the first time dr. van created a
fictional SCP to scare us we didn't
conduct any research of it after all how
can you research a non-existent joke the
joke was forgotten
just like was thrown itself after a few
days I would not remember the stone
again until many years later dr. van
started to make mistakes he never made
than this place book here an overturned
beaker bear it was all explained away
with a wave of her hand he was an old
man after all
then came the rushed report the missed
meetings the general lack of work done
his powers were taken positions degraded
yet no one bothered to seek out a reason
I tried not to let him get fired after
all he was my mentor and a respected
researcher as I've first known but even
with my hard work I could not convince
the o5 to let him stay he didn't even
bother to pack his office he just left
it alone but a note on the door saying
for the next guy his stuff got passed
around the foundation I lost track where
most of it went but I know they owe five
would be looking over the things he left
just like what they did with dr. Gant's
when he died
I visited dr. bank from time to time and
I remained working for the foundation
but my heart just wasn't in it after dr.
bang left a new researcher while digging
through dr. banks stuff found the
long-forgotten stone it is technically
an SCP albeit not designated any object
class or number the incompetent
researcher didn't find any anomalous
properties and just disposed of it the
foundation moved on to more important
stuff after all who cares about a dingy
stone with a four line report the rock
was tossed aside along with other
regular foundation garbage soon small
problems started to pop up a delivery
that was supposed to arrive in a week
took half a month due to decreased
flight an episode of a show was delayed
for months because of a lack of
personnel a highway that was planned to
be built in six months dragged into
several years but no one noticed it was
all within normal after all what human
doesn't make mistakes we are fallible
after all they aren't huge problems
anyway a few years before my retirement
I learned that the foundation recovered
the original stone along with several
hundred identical stones from a
secretive extremist group the group laid
hands on it after the botched disposal
they found the cause of the stones
properties and mass produced the stone
it was then sold to several other
activist groups who started secretly
planting these stones into UN Assemblies
g20 meetings every conference for major
organizations from APEC to NATO stealth
planes flew over municipal x' sprinkling
cities with a thin layer of ground-up
procrastinate in the dead of the night
an attempt to weaken the manger world
players and bring down their enemies the
world still went on day by day and
humanity held itself together
world leaders continued to maintain a
strained peace with the extremists and
the one
who once believed that it can bring them
victory were disappointed once again
there were no immediate effect and the
extremists soon turned to other means of
bringing down their enemies the shadow
of the stone lingered seeping into the
lives of every man an effect that no one
foresaw people all around complained
about the general slag but we're just
too apathetic to stand up for it there's
always someone else to blame some other
time to do it
Bill's took years to pass buildings took
decades to build and yet no one seemed
to care enough to fix it soon activist
groups fell apart due to lack of
interest labor unions dissolved because
no one had the will to fight for rights
members of parliament bodies were still
elected but there were no bills to pass
no issue to debate no conflict to
resolve wars ended because the soldiers
on both sides had lost the passion and
patriotism that brought them there
the o-5 council tried to prevent the
spread of this phenomenon to start the
recovery to let humanity stand back up
on its feet but no matter how hard they
tried our agents and researchers simply
just dragged the missions on for years
we didn't die out we just simply lost
our will to improve everyone just didn't
care I guess life was good fly change
there's always later
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Muslim Mookie slump god Justin day
John Porter captain Gorge fluffy dread
my archive curator neck tie verbal
cootie tench cheese whip depp's McGee
and oblong dish boy if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos and some other cool stuff as
well visit patreon.com forward slash the
volgen thank you
[Music]
you